hey what is up guys I'm KB HD here and
as we dive into Nexus 5 coverage and a
whole bunch of other awesome things
coming very soon I noticed something and
I've got on the first one to notice this
at all but I want to share it anyway
Android and Google now together right
now are poised to take over completely
at least on paper over the past few
months Google now has become a bigger
and bigger part of Android and Android
has become a bigger and bigger part of
the world's market share let me give you
a timeline when Google now first started
off it was just Google search which was
the persistent search box at the top of
your Android home screen it was always
there every Android phone had it and
that's all it did was Google search when
Android 4.1 jelly bean launched Google
now was revealed as a full app a full
service that would give you predictive
information so it would use information
about you and what you Google to give
you weather and stocks and basic
information before you needed it this
was in July 2012 and was only available
for Nexus devices since then Google now
has gotten a lot better its add a lot of
features and it's gotten more accurate
and more useful it got its first major
update in October of 2012 that plugged
it into Gmail that gave it your tracking
information for package shipping emails
Hotel information and check-in
confirmations etc it also got news cards
event cards people sports cards and more
it also added a hot phrase so every time
you said Google it would start a voice
search and that was later revised to ok
Google in December of last year it got
another major update which plugged into
some airline systems which let you use
Google now as your boarding pass to get
onto a plane I have used this and along
with all these updates that is getting
it's also quickly becoming more and more
available for just about every new
device that comes out so now every
device with Android 4.0 or later can use
Google now even if it's not a nexus
iPhone users have Google now and they're
loving it with Android 4.4 KitKat and
the Nexus 5 here in November of 2013
Google now has again taken another step
forward inside of Android
now when you swipe all the way to the
left of your home screens boom that is a
dedicated panel for Google now and
that's how you'll be able to access and
then when you swipe back over to your
home screens
you're still in Google now you're still
in Google search in Google now the whole
Google experience launcher is all
packaged together in one big Google
search and Google now app and that's why
when you swipe back in your home screen
on the Nexus 5 you can still say okay
Google and it will open a Google search
because it's still listening to you
because you're still in Google Maps it's
almost become its own little operating
system its own little ecosystem of
things that it works really well with
and things that it plugs into and plug
in to it not just the obvious things
like Google services but third-party
things like restaurants and shipping
services and and stores and events and
concerts all these other things will
filter into it because it's working with
them I'll have a link in the description
right below with like a just a giant
grid a list of official third-party
support of things that plug into Google
map before I go overboard here let me
tell you that Google now is not perfect
besides all the excellent things that
they keep adding to and all the
functionality that they keep updating
alongside it there are some glaring gaps
in functionality
Google now will allow you to open
applications on your phone so
theoretically you know you could control
your whole phone with it but it doesn't
do any sort of hardware control so if I
were to ask my phone for example ok
Google turn off Wi-Fi it wouldn't do
that it would actually give me a card
that says that this action is not
supported normally when something isn't
supported it just doesn't recognize it
and it just googles whatever you said
and gives you the results that'll help
you but because they actually have a
card there that has this device function
is not supported that means they thought
about it they thought about it but right
now it just straight-up doesn't work so
I don't know if they have plans to make
it work but I really hope they do
another thing is search with camera is
now gone like it totally disappeared and
no one actually knows why a while back
it had the functionality in full where
you could get this update where you
could say okay Google what is this
and it would open up the camera and you
could point it at something and it we
use image recognition to search for and
find a phrase that would describe what
you're looking at with the camera it was
so useful
you got logos you got text you got
landmarks all sorts of things and now
it's just not there anymore with the 2.5
update actually of Google search in the
Play Store the functionality just gets
turned off and you can see it in the
code it got turned off it has a name and
everything
please bring that back but Google now
whether you're like it or not is
everywhere iPhones have it iPads have it
Android phones have it Android tablets
have it and now even wearables that run
Android like Google glass have it and
the Google SmartWatch that will happen
will have Google now trust me there are
smartwatches that I'll run Android in
2014 people aren't going to want like
full-fledged
Android home screens on their wrists
with widgets and everything like that
they might just want Google now cards
and that's really useful when there are
refrigerators that run Android in 2015
they're not going to want a full-fledged
Android homescreen with widgets on the
refrigerator they might just want Google
now cards and that's going to be really
useful so that brings us to the whole
point of the takeover the whole mission
if you will it's a quote from sundar
Pichai who is the head of Android at
Google right now on the quote is as we
get on our journey and reach the next
billion people we want to do it on the
latest version of Android the latest
version of Android is Android 4.4 KitKat
and if you watched my last video about
it you'll know that the biggest most
important feature of it is that it's
much lighter much more memory efficient
than any other version of recent Android
has ever been and that's not only to
work on lower-end devices and older
devices like smartphones but that's to
also be the first operating system that
really makes sense to be used on
wearables like Google glass like smart
watches even appliances like
refrigerators Android 4.4 can be the
sort of backbone the skeleton behind the
scenes and Google now and its cards and
all its functionality and features can
be the face I know it's not the end of
2013 yet but for 2014 really high on the
list of things you want to look out for
in tech is going to be the proliferation
of Google now at least alongside Android
as Android spreads into new form factors
and new markets so will Google now and
Google now will be very important
alongside that and it will be taking all
over a lot of people's home screens and
that's why I said like at the beginning
of the video it looks like a takeover
waiting to happen
okay Google
you